[Music]
game from the US Championship between
Larry Christiansen playing white and
Conrad halt playing black so a match of
youth versus experience and this match
actually youth triumph because Conrad
hauled fine found a very nice resource
for black here mm-hmm
Bishop III mmm interesting well let's
see what are your threats what if I take
this pawn doesn't white create a lot of
counter threats here you might be
getting mated quite soon
what do you think yes looks dangerous
mmm so you first you missed this Quinn
takes a five idea it's one of the blocks
at one of whites main threats here
mm-hmm why do you want to play that
Bishop mu so so eagerly why is moving
the bishop so important okay so you saw
that that's very good that was very
important to see can you take that if I
rode over there yes okay very good
thinking well okay guys so the trick in
this position is that blacks main idea
rook g4 which you know looks like it
wins a queen due to this discovered
attack unfortunately it doesn't because
white can simply capture the rook and on
Queen f3 everything would be nice here
for black except the combination of the
Knights and the rook leads to checkmate
so suddenly white turns the tables and
wins the game so that is the number one
problem with the move rook g4 so black
of course noticing that he decided to
circumvent that problem by playing the
move Bishop c5 super strong move yes and
it's more powerful than Bishop e3
because the attack is on the rook rather
than just some pawn I mean it's a nice
pawn to take right but after this move
unfortunately there are many ways that
we are being threatened with mates so I
think White's counter play is very
strong here that's the downside of
having your King not sheltered by any
pawns but Bishop c5 attacks the rook so
on this move I think you just take here
and white does not even have any checks
any good checks I'm black is simply up
rook
and if he takes the bishop then you
carry out this idea you've cleared the
f-8 square for the king and your king is
going to be able to escape from checks
here sometimes the rook and the night
like in this type of formation actually
can deliver a perpetual check but not in
this position you know the night goes
here King goes here and I goes here of
course you're not going to go back
you're going to go this way and the most
white can do is give you checks this way
and on the checks end so that's the most
of the rook and the knight can
accomplish together and then you know
the Queen is going to have it say we can
actually see a few more moves of how the
game went on Larry did not just give up
so easily on Bishop Ajitha
by the way Bishop Steve I'm very
important that white cannot move away
the rook with check right that Square is
controlled by the Queen so he played d5
good try
actually the only move that actually
saves the Queen right by blocking that
diagonal d5 mm-hmm Queen e8 and the
point is again white has no time to take
that pawn because the rook is hanging
queenie eight rooks t7 rook f4 and black
is able to go on the attack here because
White's King is also not so safe rook
out for Queen Age 3 I'm not sure if you
want in the cleanest way but it seems to
have been pretty good Queen takes III
rookie for
and in this position the threats of
Ricky won and Queenie for our you know
what he's trying to do so Queen here
this move is important because you need
someone guarding the e4 square otherwise
rook e1 and Queenie four would have just
been mates so you need the Queen
guarding that's queer Queen B five and
black is going to win because he have
all these extra pawns that he has and
and the attack on the king queen e5
d6 Queen d6 rook c8 King g7 Queen f5 and
how did black win the game here
so look at all forcing moves as always
the characteristic of a good technique
good calculating technique look at all
forcing moves the most forcing kinds of
moves are checks yes you've got two
checks here one by the rook one by the
Queen but if you start with the rook
then you quickly run out of checks right
after King G tune there's no square here
there's no square here so blacks attack
has sort of reached a dead end but if
you start this way and the King goes
here how can you follow it up mm-hmm
right rook G for let's say King h3 rook
H for let's say King g3 mm-hmm yeah at
least that's right this is good enough
if you see that you can win your
opponent's Queen then it's a good enough
moment to stop calculation so I just
thought this was a pretty attractive
example on how you know you have to sort
of notice your opponent's main ideas
right you have to notice why rogue G 4
doesn't work and then the next step is
to figure out what kind of move could
renew this idea right as important in
chess not to actually give up on your
ideas but to figure out how to make them
work so if black you know just saw this
saw that it wasn't no refuted and you
know gave up he probably probably
wouldn't have won this game but black
was very persistent in figuring out a
way to actually bring this idea to life
on the board so now I'm going to give
you a little an example that is a sort
of a follow up of an example that I
showed you last night so just briefly
I'm going to show you the position so
does this position look familiar - guys
we spent quite a bit of time on it
yesterday
this ends game that arose in the game
should Penske Bartel in the US chess
league on Tuesday night guys remember
people who who were here at least what
were they so for the people who are here
who can explain to us what were the
important points from this end game and
what did we learn from it right so in
Bishop end games it's very important to
be able to fix pawns on the same color
square let's say as your opponent's
Bishop and also as your Bishop because
then there are a target for your Bishop
to attack so that is like a very
powerful strategy because in a king and
in an endgame right pawn structure takes
on greater significance you know there
are fewer pieces so ideas like mating
attacks and combinations they kind of go
down in in frequency and we becomes you
know more important and frequency is
things like a simple things like pawn
structure you know what's the placement
what's the location of my pawns are they
weak can they be attacked and captured
right so in an endgame of this type you
know the pawn structure is extremely
important if you can make targets of
your opponent's pawns then you know
that's already like you already made
plan for you right you have targets then
you can attack them you can win them you
can win the game right so this pawn can
this pawn be a target for whites Bishop
no right so it's good for black for
example to have these pawns on light
squares where this Bishop can never
touch them right now black has two pawns
on dark squares it doesn't seem like
such a big problem yet I mean obviously
I can't just capture that pawn and
attacking it either it doesn't seem like
such a big deal because it can you know
advance and if you attack it again I can
advance again and actually be
implementing the strategy of putting all
my pawns on light squares where your
Bishop can't attack them so it doesn't
seem like
such a big problem for black here
however black in this um very soon black
made a very important mistake well first
he made a normal move he moved his King
to the center actually let me just
change this black to move
he moved his King to the center we can't
argue with that strategy white push the
pawn to b5 so white is trying to create
a passed pawn on the Queen side there
was a trade and at this moment black
made this really incomprehensible move
Bishop to f8 so instead of you know
moving his King around here you know
close to the pawn he made this move and
this was a big mistake because it lost
control over the square and gave white
the chance to play here right so looks
like a small detail sorry for the people
who saw this I'm reiterating this point
but this will be important for our next
example so um now black cannot actually
avoid this type of structure you know he
cannot get both pawns on light squares
anymore he tried he made this move but
white did not give him time to advance
white advanced himself and he was able
to fix a target so in a position like
this these kinds of little details are
actually you know what the position is
all about there's nothing else going on
here
except you know hey are there targets
that I can attack right so white is
thrilled to have a fixed target on h6
and in fact white won the game
ultimately by you know trading both of
these pawns for both of these pawns and
winning the h6 pawn I can actually show
you approximately how the game ended
right so this was the position I can set
it up for you you know White's made some
progress but it wasn't cuz black was
really making any big mistakes white
played b6 King b7 and f3 f3 by the way
always a good strategy putting your
pawns on a
that that your opponents cannot attack
it with with his bishop actually there
is a deeper point to the move f3 than
simply that f3 now what should black -
let's consider a move for him
you know
Bishop III well unfortunately that gives
my king this nice square and it starts
approaching your pawn you can win this
pawn but your king is not in a very good
spot
I'm already threatening all of your
pawns right to win very quickly so I
don't know that obviously has a drawback
right which one the pawn is already g5
yeah this is what black wound up doing
but the you know I just wanted to stop
at this moment because what happened is
with the move at three white puts black
in something called what looks Wang
black actually would rather make no move
at all right over here I mean think
about it his King is fine
his Bishop is doing the maximum he could
be doing in this position which is a
protecting that pawn and be protecting
that invasion square right so the bishop
is perfect and the pawns you know they
don't want to move either because they
are preventing this King from advancing
towards them right so black would like
to pass a move but white has put him in
zoogs Wang with the move f3 black has to
make a move and yes he played the move
e5 he chose to advance his pawn okay
well there's our drawback to the move e5
and what is that which one yeah King
that goes and starts approaching the
pond
well obviously now this pawn is
threatened also this pawn is threatened
so black try to trade off as many of
them as possible before losing them all
right so there was a trade trade trade
wow they're not there's not much
material left right so you might think
hey how could black possibly lose this
he just wins this pawn and look there's
barely anything left on the board I'm
sorry well no he moved his bishop away
before yes there was also that little
problem okay King moved here and let me
see how was it
oh he actually he moved to g5 just to be
accurate so they don't just make up the
game for you even though I was tempted
at this point just to like make up some
move illustrate how it once Bishop g5 is
what actually happens okay Oh Chris Paul
white even just defended that pawn so
there's no reason to lose it right away
king c6 then he moved his King in closer
to the h6 pawn Bishop d2 King g6 Bishop
c1 Bishop to g7 King takes Bishop takes
Bishop here and how does white win this
endgame okay
yeah that's a good start obviously I
don't want to trade and I should be
moving here which one
mm-hmm yeah the main thing of course
like I'm going to be stopping your pawns
and the dark squares right from
advancing because I want to sacrifice my
bishop for it and make a draw so yeah I
mean this move was I think more accurate
Smoove and the idea is I'm keeping my
bishop on this diagonal to allow my pawn
to first advance and after I advance it
right so let's say you play here I'm
first going to advance my pawn and then
you get here and then I you know gets
you off of this diagonal when it's too
late for you to actually be stopping my
pawn from advancing there then by the
time you go here then it's too late
because I get off that Square and I
promote my pawn so we get the idea right
of how it was very limited material on
the board white one this endgame because
he had a fixed target h6 that's one
little thing won the game for white okay
so no I saw it
another interesting example today on
this theme so earlier on in this
game white had sacrificed a pawn you
know to have the advantage of the bishop
pair and to have the initiative and it
seems like you know he made the correct
decision because obviously you know
white is obviously having a lot of
initiative for the pawn deficit and it's
his move and he can even win it back so
well why don't you think for a moment
here and tell me you know what you think
is the best move for white and why
very good so I mean I'm sure a lot of
players you know would jump at the
chance to win this pawn right win the
pawn back and restore the material and
they wouldn't really even consider you
know stop to consider anything else at
this point but of course you know white
he's a you know experienced Grandmaster
so he as much as he values material he
knows that this pawn is not going
anywhere and he was looking around to
see if more useful moves exist for white
and he found the move c4 which is the
only move that actually establishes
White's advantage in this ends game
right now positionally speaking now we
understand that why such a move is
useful for whites right he's got a dark
squared Bishop you're putting the pawn
on the light square fixing that pawn on
a dark square keeping this Bishop
passive and next move you can win this
pawn and you know play your better end
the game right but what would happen
let's say if you didn't do that I mean
let's say you play rook takes a b7 so
what I mean you'll just place it for
next move
what what would black do here guys
that's a question for you you can think
about it what are you saying right black
would actually have the opportunity for
that move and that is the only move that
you know really gives black good counter
chances you've got to try to look for
active moves in chess you know you don't
want to have pieces like this on b6
right fish up staring into its own pawns
like a big pawn not all not so good so
c-4 open up the bishop and how can white
you know do anything here I mean let's
try to play a few moves here just to see
maybe you know maybe a white can get
some sort of advantage based on his
active rook on these pawns are still a
bit weak right
well for example you know in chess we
should always look at the most forcing
moves first right so what's gonna happen
if we make this trade so black has a
choice right um and as I was talking
about in my last couple of lectures one
of the big themes was it's always be
careful about going into a pure King and
pawn endgame right because you don't
know I mean yeah you can trade rooks
very nice but maybe you're just losing
so think about that for a minute just to
make sure that that's really what you
want to do or maybe you'd rather be
playing the rook endgame
so you think it's okay yes you're not
afraid that's correct yes but still you
know I just wanted to stop there for a
moment just you know - we could
reinforce the idea again how big of a
decision that is obviously white doesn't
have that much choice about the trade
because if he doesn't then the B to pawn
hangs and you know black is going to be
having a lot of counts or playing this
position so this is not a problem this
rook endgame is not a problem for black
so the most likely thing that's going to
happen is that we're going to be trading
a B now the only thing that would be a
little worrisome here you know for
whites is that white has a pawn majority
on the Queen side of three-on-two right
so it really should be easier for him to
create a passed pawn than for black
where there are more pawns over here
right and I would worry about white
having the opportunity to get an outside
passed pawn so guys all familiar with
this theme right like if white is able
to get an outside pass pawn here you
know maybe like some I don't know C pawn
and then kind of use it as a deflection
against this King get this King to the C
file this King will be on the e-file
maybe white can win but in this position
it turns out not to be really dangerous
for for black because these pawns are
going to be too close over here and
let's say you even do something like
that White's King is also not able to
get active so you can actually put your
King very actively and these but this is
not enough of an outside pass pawn for
white to win White's King is not able to
get to these pawns also these pawns give
black and nice base advantage so black
does not have anything to worry about in
this particular King and pawn endgame
but you know like I said I would I
wouldn't just automatically go forward
because you know I recognize that
there's some potential danger
in a position where my opponent has an
opportunity to more easily create a
passed pawn than I do and I'm always
thinking you know well
can white get a dangerous outside pass
pawn here but here it doesn't seem to be
the case
so definitely in that case there's no
drawback to going into pure king and
pong game in fact you might have more
problems if you keep the rooks on the
board because what is yes white is going
to play rook c7 start attacking the c4
pawn and b5 and rook here double attack
on these two pawns and you know white is
using the activity of the rook so white
you know black really is in some trouble
here wouldn't want to play this type of
rook endgame for black so so yeah
basically
and what else after the move c4 can
white do anything else
well we're threatening to maybe take
play rugby six ourselves doesn't seem
like there's a lot white can do you know
so the move c4 gives a black pretty
decent counter plan guys
I agree with that yes so that's why
you've got to be it's you know it's nice
to be a subtle chess player not being
too much of a hurry and to appreciate
the the value of fixing your opponent's
pawns on seeing color scores his bishop
also just making the bishop a very
passive piece I'm not saying like you
know black is losing here in fact black
even drew this game later on but for
sure you know he had to suffer after the
move c4
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]